from the first time I saw what
sledgehammer games was working on I was
truly inspired in every sense this game
raises the bar for the next generation
I'm proud to open our show with what I
believe is the beginning of a new era
for this franchise and once again I have
good news
Xbox owners will be the first to play
all of the add-on content here's the
first look at Call of Duty advanced
warfare on Xbox one
Hey
see you on the other side heavy enemy
fire dog truck Factory
come on resetting drop point
you still in one piece
Rachel get the door get on the ground
and legal facility
gonna share drop on this side there's a
clear spot over here I'll have to jump
down everyone get your boosters ready
Oh
you
badges wrong 227
let your position new place going 2775
alright we're moving
got your zero one three advised we are
tracking a frog storm headed your way
whoa
get down
that launcher is heavily armored you're
gonna have to find an access panel and
plan to charge since I need
in Mitchell over here you Josh
I'm worried about that time one more
time
oh let me know gotta go now
Mitchell Brad time you gotta jump it's
okay
silly other side
let go vigil strike their magic - it's
down ain't immediate medevac stay with
me you're gonna be all right
we're gonna get you home